first the guards locked it up before
they were ambushed
rumford told me they fought those
here let me open the gate adria was my
mother but i don't know much about her
she died when i was very
warriors young crusaders while the
natives were not medicine
i was able to deduce that this order was
founded
two hundred years ago just as lucky took
his army of paladin's west
but these crusaders went east on a very
different
mission
my mother had her secrets people said
she was a witch
but i never believed it
more fury
here's the key and my mother's journal
what i've seen of it is disturbing i
will go
stay here and learn asian came to me
last night i suspected what was lurking
within his troubled heart
i consoled him as best i could
regardless
wherever he's headed how did your mother
die
well details are happening
for a long time uncle deckard avoided
coming back this is where diablo drove
old king leoric mad i don't know what
really happened
i gained new power
so
um
[Music]
tristram cathedral the fallen storm
this is where the star fell
foreign
my name is and i'm cursed
once the captain of king the oryx army i
left only to honor my land and my king
no man has a greater love for his king
than i had for mine
even as i drove my blade through his
dark and corrupted heart
i'll take your fears
help me
inside
[Music]
how taste your fear
wow
i need fury
[Music]
um
he was lazarus of that i am certain he
alone had the king's ear
and whispered dark and evil magics into
it instilling the notion of an imminent
attack by west march
afraid to speak against the archbishop
the councillors nodded their empty heads
in agreement
and sent us off to die
those mushrooms are immense i gain new
[Applause]
strength
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
vowel minions stay back
back may this ledge hold
a skeleton king the power of the fallen
star
awakened me and soon all will suffer
as i have suffered gods
bring me his bones
hey i will save you
stay back
[Music]
oh thank you but why did you risk
yourself for me
i have need of your knowledge
it is wonderful to hear that leah is
well
i fear the work i learned of this secret
passage through
old maps i found
i have honored my pledge to leah and
rescued cain
all that stands between me and the
mystery of the fallen star
is the skeleton king whose return has
again
darkened tristram
uncle you're alive thanks to you
and your friend here time is running
short
what can you tell me of the fallen star
not much i'm afraid
though the prophecy of the end days
surely
points to it as a sign that the end
has begun please uncle
not more of your stories all that
matters now is that you're back